[Music]
Ready Set did you know that up to 50% of
the fruit produced in developing
countries rots I think I can predict
enabling water treatment technology to
support the unconventional natural gas
nuclear reactor that runs entirely on
nuclear waste MIT is an engine of ideas
we want a lot of ideas but it's the
execution of those the implementation of
those ideas in fact where the value is
created if you can take an idea and it
impacts or changes the world there is
nothing that's more exciting than that
we believe that soon these technologies
will revolutionize the practice of law
and our firm intends to be on the
cutting edge if every small satellite
launched in the next decade is our
technology
over 1 billion dollars could be saved so
if you want to solve a five billion
dollar problem fund up all right thank
you
[Music]
in any academic enterprise there's
always a tension between theory and
practice
but at MIT that advanced theory goes
hand in hand with advanced applications
that might use an incredibly innovative
place people are all working in
different areas they're all
communicating with each other very very
fertile ground for inventions we'd like
to solve problems and entrepreneurship
is that link between identifying
innovative ways of doing things and then
translating applying implementing them
in the solution of problems professor ed
Roberts did a study looking at the
entrepreneurial impact of MIT as a whole
and the conclusion he came to was there
are a little over 25,000 active company
started by alumni of MIT those 25800
companies employ 3.3 million people
worldwide and have revenues of nearly
two trillion dollars that would make the
ensemble of MIT alumni companies equal
to the 11th largest economy in the world
I wish I had the recipe for what makes
MIT such a fount of innovation and
entrepreneurship but I think the simple
answer is it is in our DNA
[Music]
entrepreneurship goes back to the very
founding of MIT William Barton Rogers
vision wasn't explicitly one about
entrepreneurship they didn't use the
word in the way that we use it today but
it was very much about that the
university's relationship with industry
and that became particularly important
late in the 19th century so you have
Charles stone and Edwin Webster started
a consulting firm in electrical
engineering the firm Arthur D little
it's actually founded in 1909 and Dartz
is a chemical consulting firm but grows
into one of the great management
consulting firms as a movie in the 20th
century the electrical industry
increasingly becomes the electronics
industry you have a mob oohs and the
Bose corporation Harold Edgerton known
as Doc Edgerton around here with two of
his colleagues kurma showers and angrier
forms EG&G and a consulting firm very
heavily involved in electronics and
defense
and of course after World War two a lot
of those electronics industries begin to
convert into computer industries one of
the things that's interesting though
then that happens into the 70s the
counterculture that arises which has an
ethos of liberation and personal
transformation actually gloves on to
technology and particularly the
technology of personal computers as a
mechanism for that kind of
transformation the folk heroes of the
personal computer revolution like Steve
Jobs is also very much associated with
those kind of movements and that was a
transformational moment where you saw
things really take off it wasn't just an
occasional great engineer who happened
to partner and have something happen
everybody saw this is I want to be a
rockstar I want to be an entrepreneur in
1990 I put together a proposal and said
I think we need to create an
entrepreneurship Center and it became
the first piece of what we call the MIT
entrepreneurial ecosystem the ecosystems
know one thing it's not centralized it's
a whole bunch of activities that all
somehow work together in a cooperative
way to encourage people to take their
ideas and to move them forward into the
practical world we see our roles and
giving students and faculty the tools
and techniques that they need to
actually be more effective entrepreneurs
so whether it's engineers business
students people from policy Department
everybody who has an idea and has the
idea of taking that to the market is a
part of the entrepreneurial ecosystem
now there's other parts of the ecosystem
that have evolved these educational
resources there's technical resources
there's mentoring and advice resources
Phil aghanim Center the MIT Technology
licensing office venture mentoring
service i-team's the MIT Deshpande
Santos 100k welcome to the 2010 elevator
pitch contest the MIT 100k was an
entrepreneurial competition designed to
bring together the entrepreneurial
community and not just MIT but at the
Greater Boston area we have students
working on great technologies and their
labs are looking
ways to commercialize in the hundred K
provides them with a platform to start
thinking about how they can go about
doing that to start with the elevator
pitch grand prize ananda fun 60-second
pitch get your idea out there then you
winnow down a little bit in the funnel
to the executive summary contest and
it's when you take that elevator pitch
that you gave and put it down on paper
build on it and make it sort of a
broader vision business and the judges
are maybe venture capitalists maybe
industry executives i am not completely
clear on whether it will work these look
like people should be able to get good
advice
i'm not gonna take this come back show
us that they really had something but
then that person who's sitting there
kind of leading the session will then
probe the judgments and what could they
do better how could they make this idea
better it seems to take a pretty
comprehensive approach and every day
it's not just and they have actionable
feedback that then they can take to
improve their idea for the next contest
the overall winner is polly chroma
[Applause]
[Music]
Korff MIT entrepreneurship is that it's
technology-based so we are creating the
new technologies that are gonna really
change the way people look whether it's
in medicine and energy and
communications I can't count how many
biotech companies have been founded by
MIT materials nanotechnology bows a123
Digital Equipment Corporation Tara dine
al Milam Jen's on harmonics music
systems Gillette analog devices Luke and
robotics and os oz cough there's
something about the place that instills
in these engineers and scientists just
the feeling that I can do this we can
figure this out we don't know enough to
fail and just go for it when you really
look into the roots of these companies
whichever part of MIT they came from
they touch on multiple parts of the
ecosystem and I think that that kind of
lesson is what an awful lot of people
around here appreciate our idea actually
came from a failed experiment instead of
taking the experiment throwing into the
trash we actually sat down we thought
well this this could be interesting we
first got lab space in September of 2009
and I was literally the only person
working in that lab since 2009 we've
grown to a sixth person
full-time in a company we're riding the
wave of micro RNA a new class of
molecules that was recently discovered
that's shown to be linked to all these
diseases and so it has a lot of promise
for for Diagnostics fire Flight was born
of a brilliant yet simple idea damp rag
bomb created this very powerful method
to produce micro particles by shining
bursts
of UV light on two streams of fluids
that are flowing in microfluidic
channels we can write actual barcodes on
the particle we can carry particles of
any shape venture mentoring service
evaluated that technology and then came
back to us and said we'd be interested
in working with you
the idea behind venture mentoring
service is to take members of the MIT
community many of those folks they have
good ideas and often they don't know
what to do with them we knew that it was
an interesting technology but didn't
perhaps know how to apply that to a
commercially interesting application and
so in working with the mentors and the
catalysts at some point we started to
think along the lines of Diagnostics
we'll assemble a group of experienced
entrepreneurs who are willing to donate
time and the hope is that by doing this
will significantly increase the chances
of their success as technology develops
and as time goes on I think healthcare
is gonna focus more on Diagnostics and
we hope to be a big part of that
whenever someone wants some advice on
how they start a company how they apply
for grants I'm more than willing to sit
down and help and I think it's it's the
type of ecosystem that builds on itself
so the more mentorship that a person has
given the more they're willing to give
back so we're taking the first ever
Firefly group photo
[Music]
it was actually added this pombe meeting
that I met professor Ellis acts and an
Ellis work was in that that crucial
transitional phase you know very early
Rd where nothing is proven and
everything is possible the basic idea is
to take highly purified silicon melt it
and immediately turn it into a standard
six by six inch wafer so if you can take
that step and do it much more efficient
then we dramatically impact the cost of
renewable energy and we get to that the
interesting point where solar is cheap
as electricity generated from coal in
order to commercialize technology you
have to get to a point where somebody on
the outside is gonna put up a lot of
money that great idea may not have
blossomed to a point that a professional
investor is ready to put their money
into it
to take it to the next level the
Deshpande Center is not about company
formation we're about reducing the
technical and the market uncertainty to
prepare an idea an innovation
marketplace 1366 made a bet on silicon
when 98% of the rest of the United
States was going away from silicon for
solar and so this bumbler stepped into
that gap in front of that we gave him
$50,000 to develop that idea and see
what he could do with it there could be
tremendous cost reductions by innovating
around silicon rather than going away
from silicon and to date so far that's
turned out to be correct based on the
results of the company over the last
two-plus years the power from the Sun is
about 10,000 times the average power
consumption of all of mankind that's the
primary reason that many people expect
solar to grow to be the primary source
of renewable
one of the best things about my job is
knowing that I'm one of those people out
there taking a risk
I mean what's more exciting than that to
me nothing in 1995 I was ahead of the
algorithms group and then the lab for
computer science my group was working on
algorithms in distributed networks to
manage communications better avoid
congestion so that everybody get access
to the content and there wouldn't be the
worldwide wait the first hint that there
might be a company came when we entered
the than 50k contest now called the
hundred Ted contest you know we had a
free page business plan that we
submitted not really a business plan
it's only three pages and ultimately
made it to the final six what we're
gonna do that basically like many other
companies out there is end the worldwide
wait but we intend to do it in in a way
that'll actually work you know there's a
urban legend is that Akamai won the 50k
in our year that is not true they only
announced first second and third and we
were none of those positions over time
we created a successful company but
during the 50k you know we weren't there
yet
[Music]
Akamai may be the most important and
pervasive Internet company you've never
heard of we deliver about a hundred and
thirty thousand websites if you're
getting software movies running searches
buying something on the web you're using
us today the business has been very
successful we're growing rapidly
we carry anywhere 15 to 30 percent of
web traffic you know I look at the
Internet today and I think wow we're
just at the beginning we barely
scratched the surface so I think you're
gonna see a huge influx of traffic and
applications and functionality moving
online and moving to mobile devices
there is probably nobody less likely to
be an entrepreneur than I was clueless
you know about the whole process but
there's the the facilities at MIT to
learn and it encourages you want to do
that and to work in an area like the
Internet it's at its beginnings it's the
invention of our generation it's just an
incredible opportunity and it's been
incredibly exciting the MIT 100k
culminates with a business plan contest
you get a team together to help you take
that idea from what was in your little
executive summary tear it apart and make
it ready for May when the finale is now
culminates getting you know roughly
eight nine hundred people in the Kresge
Auditorium ultimately giving away that
from the thousand dollar prize and the
winner is a clean sweep strategy hoping
that someone has a picture of our faces
from that moment we all stood up looked
utterly dumbfounded synergies are
for-profit social enterprise we provide
sanitation services in urban slums
starting in Kenya we never thought that
a development team could win the MIT
hundred K the money is great the
mentorship is awesome but the validation
that emerging markets are something that
really needs a new look and we hope that
this is the start of a revolution here
at MIT
[Music]
human beings are endowed with the
capacity to create we create because we
cannot leave without asking questions
and proposing new ideas where does that
creative idea
get harvested and then turned into
something that can get communicated the
entrepreneur is key and that whole chain
of solutions it takes somebody who says
I'm gonna do this because I really
believe it and they are the people then
who finds some way to get the money find
people who can develop the technology
and they don't give up at the heart of
everything we do
is believing that the work we do has to
have an impact in the real world and
it's that confidence that lies at the
heart of mi t--'s ongoing commitment to
innovation based entrepreneurship
[Applause]
[Music]
you